rogue planets are planets that travel
through the universe alone they inhabit
the dark and vast space between the
stars
drifting alone through eternal darkness
no light warms their surfaces and
they're exposed to the freezing cold of
outer space they know no seasons no days
and no nights which could give away the
passing of time and yet rogue planets
might carry alien life to all corners of
the galaxy how would that work and how
does a planet become a rogue anyway
[Music]
there are several very different things
that get called rogue planets for
example sub-brown dwarfs gas giants that
form from collapsing gas clouds and at
the boring little brothers of brown
dwarfs they're a sort of failed star and
we'll now stop talking about them a far
more interesting sorted rogue are
terrestrial planets similar to earth
that got kicked out of their planetary
system young star systems aren't
dangerous places where proto planets are
battling for the available mass guzzling
up as much material as possible in this
fight for dominance they collide with
each other or get dangerously close to
each other's orbits if a very massive
planet moves its orbit closer to the
star it can kick smaller planets out of
the system but just because a planet has
survived the growing pains of formation
doesn't mean it's safe planetary systems
can be disrupted by flybys from stars or
black holes at any point up to half of
all planets born could end up as rogues
the scientists don't agree on the
numbers but it's likely that at the very
least there are billions of rogue can
it's in the Milky Way alone
most rogues will share the same
depressing fate as their star becomes
smaller day by day the planet's surface
quickly cools down to minus 270 degrees
Celsius if they have oceans they'll
freeze and become as hard as bedrock
their atmospheres will sink down to the
surface and eventually freeze to but
weirdly enough some of these frozen dark
deserts could Harbor life to understand
how let's imagine a planet similar to
earth in the same order of magnitude in
terms of mass and Composition if we put
it into deep space how could it still
support life as far as we understand the
nature of life there is one
indispensable ingredient it needs liquid
water water is important because it
mixes things both matter and energy
which lets interesting chemistry happen
like life so our planet needs enough
energy to keep at least a part of our
oceans warm enough to sustain liquid
water annoyingly about 99.97% of Earth's
energy budget comes from the Sun so our
imaginary rogue earth needs to work with
the 0.03 percent of energy it has left
which almost exclusively comes from its
hot Center Earth's inner core is a giant
metal ball about as hot as the surface
of the Sun that surrounded by the outer
core made up of liquid metals that are
very very slowly solidifying releasing a
lot of heat in the process as long as
this process is ongoing our planet will
be geologically active with solid and
liquid material moving around and
transporting energy to the surface where
it can be harnessed as geothermal energy
while the hot core of every planet will
cool off eventually this process takes
billions of years enough time for life
to come into existence and thrive
[Music]
there's even one scenario that could
allow an earth-like planet to have
oceans that are not frozen over if the
planet had an extremely dense and high
pressure hydrogen atmosphere the gas
would not freeze and could trap enough
of the heat trying to escape the planet
to enable oceans that extend all the way
to the surface and there's another
possible way to stay warm moons if a ro
planet brings a moon or more along with
them a large enough moon could inject
additional energy into the system via
tidal forces these forces stretch and
squeeze the planet a little bit every
day like kneading dough keeping it warm
but the most likely scenario for a rogue
bearing life is one with sub Glacial
oceans under a kilometer thick layer of
mostly water ice these are not
completely absurd since we already have
a few of them in the solar system so how
could life sustain itself at the bottom
of a completely dark cold ocean on earth
deep down in our oceans in complete
darkness in volcanically active areas
there are hydrothermal vents called
black smokers they spew out a cloud of
black material and hot water providing a
constant flow of minerals from Earth's
mantle bacteria feed on the minerals and
producer organic materials which
attracts crustaceans bivalves snails
fish octopus and tube worms up to 2
metres long
not only are hydrothermal vents home to
an incredibly diverse group of living
beings but also a contender for the
place where life could have begun on
earth billions of years ago in the dark
ocean of a rogue planet similar events
or volcanic activity could be the
starting point and basis for complex
ecosystems we can only imagine right now
one upside an ecosystem in a rogue
planet ocean has is that the environment
is extremely stable the thick ice sheet
protects it from all sorts of extinction
events and as long as the energy from
the core keeps on coming things stay
pretty much the same the most likely
forms of life are bacteria and other
microorganisms but given enough time
more complex alien animals could feed on
the smaller beings and
it's not impossible that intelligent
life could emerge in such an environment
if it did it would find itself in a
pretty weird world constricted by an
impassable wall of rock-hard ice at the
top and bedrock at the bottom without
any plants to store star energy there
would be no wood oil or coal even if
there were it's not like you'd discover
fire at the bottom of an ocean without
this energy metals may never be forged
into useful things our intelligent alien
friends might never break through the
ice they might never realize that there
is such a thing as outside and assumed
that their small world is all there is
millions of generations might live and
die in these dark oceans ignorant of the
unbelievably big universe above the ice
until the core of their planet cools off
and all life vanishes as the oceans
completely freeze the remnants of
cultures and ecosystems will be trapped
in an icy grave forever if you think
about it it might be better not to be
aware of all that but the concept is
disturbing and exciting the universe
might be teeming with life trapped on
planets that are basically impossible to
leave worlds like this could frequently
pass the solar system without us even
knowing maybe one day in the far future
humans will set foot on one of these
frozen worlds and try to say hello okay
so we love gloomy future scenarios but
let's go back to the present for a
different kind of surprise many of you
want to know how we make our videos so
we made a video about that course Kazan
teamed up with Skillshare our favorite
online learning community for creators
to make a three-part series of classes
where you can learn our unique animation
style with scenes from our videos
but we're not the only ones telling you
our tips and tricks they're a skill
shared Premium Membership gives you
unlimited access to more than 25,000
classes in all kinds of skills like
writing design and animation from
experts who know their stuff the Premium
Membership is as low as $10 a month but
as a treat the first 1,000 people to use
the link in the description will get
their first two months for free if
you've always wanted to see how we
animate our videos and learn to do it
yourself this is your chance
[Music]
you